burg a key element of your response to
failing schools in New York City was a
dramatic increase in public charter
schools as president would you pursue
that same strategy and seek to expand
charter schools nationwide I'm not sure
they're appropriate every place I can
only tell you in New York they provided
parents with an alternative to send
students to them
we had the charter schools are mixed in
with the non charter public schools
because our charter schools are public
schools as well they've helped each
other I'm sort of statistic the other
day when I came into office 0 New York
City schools were in the top 25 of the
state when I left 23 out of 25 were from
New York City we've cut the gap between
the rich and the poor we've made an
enormous difference in all of the the
options that parents have like raise
teachers salaries by 43 percent I put an
extra five billion dollars into our
school system
I value education it is the only ways to
solve the poverty problem is to get
people a good education and rather than
just talk about it in New York we
actually did it senator
you